richard branson der mann mit dem
goldenen händchen und dem milliardär
fläche er ist sagenhaft reich berühmt
wie ein rockstar und scheint sich immer
gut zu amüsieren
bin ich habe riesiges glück gehabt ich
habe jede minute meines lebens genossen
ich würde mit niemandem tauschen wollen
reichtum beeindruckt ihn nicht ihm geht
es eher um die frage habe ich spaß man
braucht ein gleichgewicht branson hat
einen sexy namen virgin in marken gold
verwandelt mit über 300 waren und
dienstleistungen von rock über
flugreisen bis hin zu handys und zügen
wir haben es mit den fetten unternehmen
aufgenommen da nicht wirklich viel über
den verbraucher nachgedacht haben und
wir sind hin und haben sie aufgerüttelt
wenn man die risiken analysieren würde
die reingegangen ist würde man nicht
mitmachen denn keine risikoanalyse würde
sagen mach weiter so um alles über
wasser zu halten wurde branson zu seinem
eigenen besten werber indem er abenteuer
und spaß auslebte und vorn und dafür
sein eigenes leben aufs spiel setze ich
habe vermutlich fast keine gelegenheit
ausgelassen um zu versuchen mich
umzubringen und ich habe das große glück
heute hier zu sein um über diese
geschichten zu sprechen
[Musik]
wenn es so einen titel gäbe wäre richard
branson vielleicht wirklich der
interessanteste mann der welt
besitzt seine eigene insel fliegt mit
ballons um den globus arbeitet mit den
großen der welt zusammen und plant ein
virgin ibo zum unerforschten meeresgrund
zu bringen die außen vor sein bisheriges
kannte es das abenteuer man lebt nur
einmal und wir akzeptieren dass es mit
risiken verbunden ist etwas zu tun was
die menschheit noch nicht getan hat aber
wir tun es mit offenen augen
bremsen verbrachte einen großteil seines
lebens auf dem hochseil des
unternehmerischen risikos
er häufte ein vermögen von mehr als vier
milliarden dollar
ich war nie daran interessiert geld zu
verdienen habe ich meine viele leute
werden sagen das ist leicht zu sagen wie
viel geld gemacht hat aber ich war
einfach daran interessiert dinge zu
schaffen dinge auf die ich stolz sein
kann und eine menge spaß dabei zu haben
wird charles nicolas branson wurde am 18
juli 1950 am stadtrand von london
geboren
sein vater war rechtsanwalt seine mutter
eine ehemalige flugbegleiterin als
schwerer legastheniker konnte er im
alter von acht jahren kaum lesen und war
mit zahlen hoffnungslos überfordert ist
ein fall die schule war schmerzhaft die
schaute auf eine tafel mein verstand
nichts
interessanterweise wenn man sich die
geschichten von legasthenikern anguckt
schneiden sie oft ganz besonders gut ab
weil er sich auf die bereiche
konzentrieren in denen
sie lernen sich ja sehr schulsachen zu
delegieren mit paul war der engste
freund und später geschäftspartner von
grenzen
ich habe bei richard immer gedacht er
wird die welt verändern
man konnte schon früh erkennen dass er
qualitäten hatte die unter all den
anderen freunden die wir hatten nicht
üblich waren wir machten immer mutproben
saßen auf beiden seiten der weißen linie
und es ging darum wer sich als letzter
bewegt wenn das auto die straße runter
kommt richard gewann immer
aber branson hatte eine starke
unternehmerische ader mit 13 versuchte
er weihnachtsbäume zu verkaufen er
versuchte sittiche zu züchten
mit 15 beschloss er eine nationale
studentenzeitung zu gründen newspaper
ich arbeitete von einer telefonzelle an
der schule aus brief coca cola anrief
leute an ob sie für die zeitschrift
schreiben wollen rief die barclays bank
an ob sie eine anzeige schalten diese
schlangen von leuten vor der
telefonzelle sich noch mehr geld ein wie
die zeitschrift student war ein
sofortiger erfolg mit einer auflage von
50.000 stück graham
reisereporter für den landen telegraph
und berichtete über 20 jahre lang über
grenzen
obwohl ein kind der 60er jahre war weil
man etwas unbeholfen ich glaube was
passierte war dass das unternehmen ihm
einen wortschatz seine tiefe gab und von
da an ging es weiter
1970 gründete grenzen einen
versandhandel für discount klappen mit
dem erhofften geld für die zeitschrift
zu bekommen die erste aufgabe bestand
darin einen namen zu finden summerjam
anschlug schlitz des crackers vor wir
hatten alte vinyl platten die immer
wieder verrutschten und jemand anderes
lacht für weißt du warum nicht virgin
wir sind doch alle jungfrauen ich dachte
plötzlich ich bin nun frau im geschäft
weiß durch ich könnte auch in anderen
dingen eine jungfrau sein also warum
nicht virgin
ein post streik brachte den platten
versands 1971 fast zum erliegen
princeton beschloss einen plattenladen
zu eröffnen einen mit kopfhörern und
wasser kissen der sich an jüngere leute
richtet seinen treffer bransons cousin
war sein erster plattenkäufer und der
spätere leiter von virgin records alle
wurden gleich bezahlt so dass man das
gefühl hatte niemand darf mehr geld
verdienen als die anderen aber wenn man
mal darüber nachdenkt war es eigentlich
ganz praktisch denn so konnte man allen
weniger zahlen
einige der leute die für richard in den
plattenläden in notting hill gearbeitet
haben haben plagen gestohlen und sie
waren total erstaunt als richards sie
wegen diebstahls gefeuert hat er war vom
ersten tag an darauf getrimmt ein
geschäftsmann zu sein
fünf monate nach der eröffnung des
ladens wurde bremsen plötzlich wegen
steuerhinterziehung verhaftet
er hatte seine platten zum teil billiger
angeboten alle einen weg gefunden hatte
die schallplatten steuer zu umgehen
er verbrachte eine nacht im gefängnis
und seine eltern mussten ihr haus
beleihen um ihn rauszuholen
er dachte um mitmischen zu können müsste
er steuern umgehen das muss ein großer
schock für ihn gewesen sein er war
extrem verärgert aber er hat sich
tadellos verhalten niemand sonst bekam
irgendwelche strafen
[Musik]
ich hatte es geschafft ein
strafrechtliches verfahren zu vermeiden
indem er bezahlte was verlangt wurde und
wir haben unsere plattenläden sehr
schnell erweitert so dass wir den umsatz
hatten um die schulden abzubezahlen
seitdem habe ich dafür gesorgt dass
alles sauber bleibt damit wir uns keine
sorgen machen mussten dass jemand eine
tür klopft
um 150.000 dollar bußgeld zu begleichen
an einen gerichtsprozess oder sogar eine
haftstrafe zu umgehen gründete branson
ein aufnahmestudio und ein neues
plattenlabel new record label zusammen
mit seinem cousin
erster vertragspartner war ein
unbekannter
folkloristisch field mit einem seltsamen
instrumental album namens tubular bells
wir haben uns gefragt ob wir wetten
sollten wie oft sich dieses album wohl
verkaufen würde ich dachte vielleicht
20.000 mal was mir zu der zeit viel
erschien abermillionen später sie wissen
schon eine ganz andere geschichte 16
millionen um genau zu sein über nacht
machte die platte virgin bekannt vorne
ab und richard branson noch nicht ganz
23 zum millionär branson steckte all
seine gewinne in neue künstler und
unternehmen aber das verunsicherte seine
partner
paul leistete so viel widerstand das
bremsen ihn aus seite ich glaube nicht
dass wir genug cash flow hatten um das
geschäft weiter so expandieren zu können
und ich lag falsch ich bin vielleicht
bereit mehr einzusetzen als ich anderen
leuten raten würde es gibt fälle wo ich
meine frau dazu gebracht habe ein papier
zu unterschreiben und sie haben nicht
gemerkt dass das haus für dieses
geschäft aufs spiel gesetzt wird
1984 lebte richard branson das leben
eines rock'n roll königs ihm gehörte
diese insel auf den britischen
jungferninseln
records war eines der erfolgreichsten
unabhängigen labels der welt
der sex pistols
simple minds human league culture club
wahren verkaufsschlager
branson war reich und wollte das geld
ausgeben aus heiterem himmel rief einen
versicherungs anwalt namens randolph
fehlt an und bat branson um hilfe bei
einer transatlantischen fluggesellschaft
seinen treffer meiner anderen am partner
rauften sich die haare weil ich
plötzlich sagte wisst ihr was ich hasse
es mit den airlines anderer leute zu
reisen und wir können das besser machen
meine anteile die ich damals besaß 15
prozent der gesamten virgin group wurden
ziemlich wertvoll also war ich entsetzt
und sagte das ist der anfang vom ende
unserer beziehung
prinzen startete seine fluggesellschaft
mit einer gebrauchten 747 der von
boeing sagte das unternehmen noch
wir sind die leute die in die sex
pistols und die rolling stones gebracht
haben
sagte nur scherzhaft nun an einem
solchen namen hoffen wir mal dass das
was wird wir werden es versuchen
[Musik]
nachdem er viel heraus gekauft hatte
beschloss branson eine bessere mischung
aus economy und business class tarifen
anzubieten wobei der schwerpunkt auf
nonstop spaß lag
der eröffnungs flug von london nach new
york gab den ton an
ich kann ihnen sagen das war eine orgie
es war wild es wurde getrunken wir waren
oben ohne models in flugzeugen ist
einfach eine party und wirtschaft gab
den ton an
die erste person die branson einstellte
war eine führungskraft bei virgin
atlantic ohne tor die erst als ich die
tür des flugzeugs im new yorker öffnete
war dass wir in champagner korken aus
der flasche kommt ich glaube es wurde
nie so viel champagner getrunken wie auf
diesem parcours
mit nur einem flugzeug und einer strecke
war bransons erstes problem die werbe
und promotion er hatte nicht das
werbebudget um mit british airways und
in anderen riesigen fluggesellschaften
zu konkurrieren also nahm er die sache
selbst in die hand und begann eine reihe
atemberaubender ballon & boat trip
virgin airlines schnell bekannt machen
sollte haushoch dieses der beginn eines
großen abenteuers sein flug über den
atlantik
1987 faszinierte die medien wochenlang
fünf menschen waren bei früheren
versuchen ums leben gekommen berlins
trend war bremsens co pilot
belegte sein leben ganz in meine hände
und ich musste auf ihn aufpassen
als sie die irische see erreichten sie
schleuderten heftige winde den ballon
gegen die wellen
mein partner der mehr erfahrung mit
ballonfahren hatte sprang aus dem ballon
blieb allein zurück und der ballon stieg
auf 10 15.000 fuß
ich war im wasser ridge im ballon und er
wusste nicht wirklich wie das
funktioniert ich hatte noch nie so viel
angst in meinem leben
grenzen schaffte es den ballon
herunterzuholen und sprang ins eiskalte
wasser
ein hubschrauber der luftstreitkräfte
wollte ihn zusammen mit peer heraus der
nach zwei stunden schwimmen fast
gestorben war
richard ist eine mischung aus live
niveau und der teller er würde ja sagen
ich fahre mit dem ballon weil es gute
werbung für die firma ist
aber er tut das weil es ihm spaß macht
wenn er eine katze wäre wir wer schon
beim dritten set von neun leben ende
1989 vergrößerte sich richard bransons
welt an allen fronten er heiratete seine
langjährige partnerin john tempelmann
auf necker island
das paar hatte schon zwei kinder den
vierjährigen sam und die achtjährige
rolli auch das unternehmen expandierte
branson hatte die virgin group 1986 an
die börse gebracht was mehr als 56
millionen dollar einbrachte
ich glaube nicht dass ein börsengang die
art wie wir unsere geschäftig führen
sehr verändern wird das erwies sich als
falsch es machte sehr wohl einen
unterschied
bremsen verabscheute es seinem
aufsichtsrat rechenschaft abzulegen und
kaufte virgin zurück nun lenkte er ein
kleines aber prekäres imperium mit einer
airline die ständig gefahr lief
unterzugehen auf den andern und
schlimmer noch british airways war
entschlossen seinen aufstrebenden
rivalen zu vernichten
die rivalität zwischen british airways
und virgin atlantic war mir immer ein
rätsel
ich glaube es lag am britischen
establishments
sie sahen diesen jungen rücksichtslosen
emporkömmling mit langen haaren
das hat sie einfach recht verärgert
so sehr dass british airways 1991 etwas
startete ist die presse als kampagne der
schmutzigen tricks bezeichnete bei hat
team sind sie hatten teams hinter
verschlossenen türen die sich illegal
zugang zu unseren computer daten
verschafften sich ihren vorgaben von
virgin atlantic zu sein wir hatten flüge
gestrichen und pochten sie auf british
airways sie haben leute die meine müller
einmal durchsuchte mülleimer unserer
klubs durchsuchten irgendeinen schmutz
über uns zu finden sie platzierten
stories in der presse nicht so weit
und das schlimmste branson war überzeugt
dass british airways gerüchte schürze
virgin sei insolvent und stehe kurz vor
dem untergang
geweiht leiter von virgin galactic und
arbeitet seit 1987 eng mit branson
zusammen jeden tag an dem du mit leeren
sitzen ab hebst verlierst du geld wenn
also jemand passagiere davon überzeugt
nicht bei einer bestimmten airline zu
buchen weil sie glauben dass sie pleite
geht dann wird sie pleite gehen branson
kämpfte darum virgin atlantic am leben
zu erhalten und wieder einmal setzte er
dafür sein leben aufs spiel tut er
startete zu einer weiteren gefährlichen
ballonfahrt dieses mal über den pazifik
inmitten über dem pazifik verloren wir
zwei volle treibstofftanks und wir
wussten nicht ob wir noch genug haben um
es zu schaffen
wir mussten diesen ballon mit einer
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit von über
180 meilen pro stunde fliegen und wir
wurden ja nur vom wind angetrieben also
waren nicht chancen total gering
aber dann kamen wir genau den kern des
jetstreams und sahen plötzlich wie der
geschwindigkeitsmesser stieg
180 190 200 210 220
ich bin kein religiöser mensch alles war
als ob jemand da oben diesen ballon
genommen und angeschoben hatte mitten
durch den jetstream
branson und linz trends stürzten über
einem zugefrorenen see 300 meilen vom
nächsten wohnort entfernt wir verfehlten
unser ziel um dreieinhalb tausend meilen
und landeten in der arktis in einem
schneesturm bei minus 60 grad aber wir
hätten nicht glücklicher sein können in
dem moment als bremsen ausstieg so war
er tatsächlich schon ein superstar auch
sein plattenlabel lief heißt virgin
records nahm janet jackson und die
rolling stones unter vertrag
aber die schmutzkampagne von british
airways gegen virgin atlantic machte es
unmöglich kredite zu bekommen würde und
die airline zu retten musste bremsen die
härteste entscheidung seines lebens
treffen er beschloss seine geliebte
plattenfirma zu verkaufen penny peck war
31 jahre lang seine persönliche
assistentin jeder war furchtbar
geschockt ich meine wichert war noch
geschockte als alle anderen und er
weinte und weinte und weinte es war als
würde man ein kind verkaufen sagt es den
personalfragen tränen aus rannte zurück
zu meinem haus und kam an diesem schild
vorbei auf dem stand per enzen verkauft
für eine milliarde soll
man mir wurde klar dass das leben kann
nicht so schlecht waren er hat die
zukunft von virgin atlantic gesichert
weil er danach genug kapital hatte um
jedem konkurrenten ins gesicht schauen
und sagen zu können weißt du was ich
kann das genauso lange aussetzen wie du
die leute sagten damals wir seien
verrückt die plattenfirmen
das geld in eine airline zu stecken aber
später ist die plattenindustrie er
zusammengebrochen und die flugindustrie
hat sich nicht so schlecht für uns
entwickelt einen monat nach dem
milliardenschweren deal verklagte
branson british airways wegen
verleumdung die fluggesellschaft einigte
sich außergerichtlich und zahlte 1,1
millionen dollar
wir haben den höchsten schadenersatz
einer verleumdungs fälle gewonnen und
sie mussten sich öffentlich
entschuldigen
[Musik]
richard branson war überglücklich dieser
tag war wahrscheinlich einer der
großartigsten seiner karriere er hatte
es geschafft er hat die mächtige british
airways zu treten
an diesem abend telefonierte er mit
verschiedenen leuten und er hatte diese
entschlossenheit in seiner stimme das
war der moment er wollte virgin atlantic
zu einem weltweiten erfolg machen er
wollte es nehmen und es auf der ganzen
welt ausbauen
nachdem er 1992 virgin records für eine
milliarde dollar verkauft hatte bei
richard branson bereit sein wertvollstes
gut zu verwerten die marke wird in
mainz wurde plötzlich klar dass wir
etwas haben das wir schützen und pflegen
müssen die marke ist letztlich das worum
es bei virgin geht
branson war die marke und er hat sie
unermüdlich gefördert bis heute hat er
über 300 produkte und dienstleistungen
wird imitiert ich glaube wenn man etwas
schafft auf das man stolz sein kann dann
wird es wahrscheinlich erfolgreich sein
aber sind denke ich dachte nicht los wir
bringen diese marke jetzt in allen
möglichen bereichen
ich dachte man könnte es mit
fitnessstudios probieren oder mit dem
mobilfunkgeschäft
einige versuche wie virgin breit und
virgin cola verpufften schnell
in chains startete stoppen
die infrastruktur war marode
und es dauerte jahre bis die züge
pünktlich vor
aber andere vorstöße hatten
atemberaubenden erfolglos
1999 stieß branson auf eine goldader er
schloss sich mit dienstleistern zusammen
um virgin mobile zu gründen sie
lieferten das netz er das marketing und
den namen
sowie die innovative idee die kunden
während der fahrt bezahlen zu lassen
gerd schmitz professor an der school of
business der columbia university ist
experte für markenbildung der wert einer
marke liegt wirklich in den
immateriellen werten kunden kaufen nicht
nur produkte verkaufen nicht nur
funktionalität sie kaufen auch ein image
sie kaufen einen lebensstil sie kaufen
eine erfahrung er steht für bestimmte
dinge er steht für service für kunden
erlebnis für innovation für spaß
branson war jetzt der business könig
1999 wurde er vom königshaus seines
landes geehrt die königin schlug ihn zum
ritter als ikone des millenniums für
seinen beitrag zum handeln
[Musik]
fünf jahre später brachte er virgin
mobile an die börse nach eigenen angaben
wurde das unternehmen mit 15 milliarden
dollar bewertet
[Musik]
jedes unternehmen der virgin group
bleibt unabhängig
so dass kein misserfolg das imperium zu
fall bringen kann trotzdem stellen
analysten regelmäßig den wert der virgin
group in frage die sich immer noch in
privater hand befindet die schlagzeilen
lauten wann wird bransons ballon platzen
jedes mal wenn wir etwas neues starteten
extra passiert die marke zu sehr und
manchmal sagen sie weit daneben die
virgin group gründete immer wieder neue
unternehmen
2004 kündigte branson eines seiner
fantasievollsten an
er will menschen ins weltall bringen
angefangen bei seiner eigenen mutter ich
glaube wir stehen 18 monate vor dem
start ins all und ist damit vor dem
beginn eines völlig neuen bereich der
kommerziellen raumfahrt
hoffentlich werden hunderte wenn nicht
tausende von menschen die möglichkeit
haben astronaut zu werden und ins all zu
fliegen
es ist ein enormes risiko es ist als
würde man seinen namen seine marke auf
ein formel 1 rennwagen setzen es ist
toll wenn er gewinnt aber wenn er sich
irgendwo mein beton nospickel hat das
eine menge nachteile bremsen diente die
marke virgin 2006 noch weiter aus 6 da
seine airline tonnen von co2 in die
atmosphäre spucken
verpflichtete er sich alle gewinne
seiner transportunternehmen in den
nächsten zehn jahren ungefähr 3
milliarden dollar in die forschung für
einen umweltfreundlichen biokraftstoff
zu investieren
und er rief den ältestenrat ins leben
ein kriseninterventionsteam team unter
der leitung von nelson mandela
55 jahre alt hatte gutes geld verdient
und konnte so gut wie jeden anrufen und
dinge durchsetzen plötzlich war ich in
einer situation in der ich vielleicht
etwas in der welt bewirken konnte
kritiker machten sich über den neuen
sozialen branson lustig und verwiesen
auf die offshore steuer oder die er seit
jahren nutzt um sein vermögen zu
schützen ich glaube nicht dass richard
sich von den anderen sehr reichen
geschäftsleuten unterscheidet er hat
heerscharen von buchhaltern und anwälten
die ihm sagen wir wissen wo sie ihr geld
verstecken können ist
eher der unternehmer des volkes nur bis
zu einem gewissen punkt branson war
nicht in der lage sein gesamtes vermögen
zu schützen virgin america hatte einen
schweren start und verlor fast 400
millionen dollar bevor es im dritten
quartal 2010 begann gewinn zu machen
mit anfang 60 der virgin könig eine
lange und aufregende reise hinter sich
branson hat sich sein glück selbst
erarbeitet er war sehr sehr gut darin es
ist nicht nur ein goldenes händchen er
hat dafür gearbeitet
natürlich treibt ihm das geld an aber
reichtum beeindruckt ihn nicht sondern
eher die frage habe ich spaß habe ich
aufregung man braucht ein gleichgewicht
ich bin extra forschen ich hatte
außerordentliches glück ich habe jede
minute meines lebens genossen in zukunft
werde ich die meiste zeit damit
verbringen gemeinnützige unternehmen zu
gründen und sie dabei zu beobachten wie
sie einige der großen probleme der welt
angehen da aber gleichzeitig werden wir
immer noch wunderbare abenteuer erleben
wir werden in den weltraum fliegen auf
den grund der ozeane gehen und uns immer
noch anstrengend meine kinder und die
menschen um mich herum herausfordert
pico und eine menge spaß haben
[Musik]